lidl a voisins le bretonneux des ménages
de quelques centaines de mètres un
supermarché plus grands qui nécessite
l'embauché de nouveaux employés pour
recruter liddell s'est associé à pôle
emploi le besoin a été formulée pour
quinze candidats formés et recrutés à
l'issue de la préparation opérationnelle
à l'embauché
donc nous avons organisé plusieurs
sessions de recrutement depuis décembre
2020 au total six ou sept sessions de
recrutement et hautmont a dédié
quelques-unes pour le public jeune et
cela s'inscrit dans le plan de relance
gouvernemental
un jeune une solution mais les
recrutements ne concerne pas que les
jeunes et les contrats proposés par lidl
et pôle emploi sont variés on recrute
avec pôle emploi des profils qui vend
deux employés polyvalents étudiants donc
partir de 7h 10h 14h par semaine des
profils employés polyvalents 30 heures
et également d azur manager 36,75 une
formation en interne est prévu en
fonction des besoins
ici il n'est pas nécessaire d'avoir de
diplômes ni devenir du secteur
d'activité des supermarchés
moi j'ai été responsable aussi d'un
atelier bon c'était complètement un
autre univers c'est dans la bijouterie
mais je voulais rester sur la même
dynamique gérer une équipe être
en étroite collaboration avec tous ceux
qui m'entourent
donc on m'a proposé cela et puis on a
fait les démarches nécessaires avant je
travaille dans la restauration
donc c'est pour moi j'ai toujours c'est
un peu pareil contrats avec des clients
au début ça fait deux semaines
d'intervention appelé âgées signer le
contrat signé
après j'avais une période de deux mois
au chili ont accepté j'essaie content si
une partie de l'équipe a déjà été
recruté des postes sont toujours à
pourvoir dans ce nouveau supermarché il
ouvrira le 26 mai